when it comes to Star Wars everything
old is new again from one movie to the
next the Galactic space saga has story
beats and themes that echo with each new
installment George Lucas himself even
says that his prequel trilogy rhymes
with the original movies he made so with
episode 9 on the horizon it's a great
time to look back and see if The
Adventures of Luke Leia and Hans contain
any hints about what's to come next
here are some crazy hidden details that
predict the plot of Star Trek episode 9
when Return of the Jedi concluded the
original trilogy back in 1983 fans were
eager to see how the epic fight between
Luke Skywalker and his father the fallen
Jedi Anakin Skywalker would play out in
just the previous movie audiences were
shocked to discover that the movie's big
villain dark Vader was actually Luke's
dark father it was a twist that no one
could have seen coming and impact
theaters to capacity when the follow-up
came a few years later so when the
father-and-son duo's epic fight ended
with dark Vader actually becoming light
Vader we got a pretty cool moment of
closure that a lot of hardcore fans may
not have ever actually noticed I'll not
leave you here I've got to save you did
you catch that hidden detail dark Vader
straight-up said Luke saved him you
probably can't even believe you missed
that the first time you saw a Jedi come
home now with the new trilogies emphasis
on the relationship between ray and Rilo
Kiley's there's a good bet that will see
another similar moment of redemption for
dark Vader's dark grandson before the
credits can roll for the final time of
all the original trilogy's most beloved
characters none are more beloved than
Chewbacca the cookie who joined Hans as
the copilot's of the Millenium Balkin
everyone knows Chewie has gotten Hans
and Luke out of a lot of tight scrapes
in the movies because he's so good with
tech but which you may not have noticed
was that one scene in a new hope when he
uses his advanced technological
abilities to actually receive messages
from across the galaxy just Finnick
you can have a good time you may not
have realized how important the scene
was the first time you watch the movie
but now that you can see how chewy
cookie can use a tecmo chair to talk to
women in space there's a good chance
this detail will come back around and
help Finn and Pope communicate across
vast distances with Ray as they fight
against the bad guys
general Hux and Captain plasma won't
have any idea what hit him in the early
days of Star Wars audiences were
probably a little surprised when the
dead obi-wan Kenobi started whispering
battle secrets to Luke from beyond the
grave but by the time Jedi come home
debuted in theaters horse ghosts were
actually a lot more common than you may
have realized if you pay close attention
to the end of the film you'll see that
force ghosts are actually able to appear
whenever and wherever they want it's
true obi-wan Yoda and even Anakin have
all made post-mortem appearances you
might have missed if you weren't paying
attention thanks a lot you guys
in truth only the most die-hard fans
know that it's not that hard for a Jedi
to show up as a glowing forced ghost so
now that Luke Skywalker has joined his
dad in Jedi heaven is there any doubt
he'll pop up again to show Rey the path
to victory over Rilo Kiley's in his fist
order
Luke's already proven he's a badass he
went up against Jabba the Hutt and
survived he's great with a sword and he
can project a duplicate of himself
across entire galaxies a little thing
like turning into an empty robe isn't
going to stop a link from helping Rey
get a final victory against the tank
side look who's here young people it's
not other than Duke fartknocker
if you thought porks were new in the
past Jedi buckle your butternuts link
Skywalker Forks have actually been in
every star movie and there'll be a big
part of episode 9 we know exactly what
you're thinking ain't no ports and Jedi
come home or is they no Jedi mind sticks
for this one there's been porks all
along if you were looking remember the
trash squeezer Hans and Leia fell into
take a look e there's a pork some
stormtroopers our pork stew and it gets
even crazier the Midd after credit scene
and the second one was taken from an
unreleased Easter special Greg Lucas
made called pork Tuesday host potato
explaining how porks our baby cookies
it's a galaxy of fun dark Vader hides
ports for Empire
and chewy makes a terrible supper
mistake but what support got to do with
Star Wars 9 well it's no accident that
the scene was recycled in the fast Jedi
there are no accidents in the Star Force
only forces we haven't got a second the
loop but that's not all
no there's so much more beginning with
legendary Star Wars creator George Lucas
himself if you look closely at the mole
on his left hand you can see it's
actually the missing piece of the
marauders map of Hogwarts that r2d2 was
hiding in episode 7 hey Forrest wake the
[ __ ] up and if you follow the map it
brings you to Lucas's famed Moonraker
ranch where he keeps all of his most
original ideas under lock and key and
there and his underground vaults is the
script for episode 9 which contains all
the secrets of the Illuminati like the
fates of rival Kiley and general Leia
and Pope and thin and big mclarge huge
and the droids and Jan top and Rosa's
true identity and at last we finally
discover that Ray's real parents are
actually
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Star Wars are coming soon subscribe to
our YouTube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Music]